good morning I'm Adrian Dix BC's
minister of Health joining me today is
Dr Bonnie Henry VC's provincial Health
officer we're grateful to be here on the
traditional territories of the LA Quang
and speaking people the sangees and the
Esquimalt First Nations grateful to be
here on their lands
since September we've all been focused
on The Importance of Being prepared for
Respiratory illness season and as we
know from our experience and what we're
seeing in BC and in other jurisdictions
across Canada and around the world the
season is now upon us and covid-19 is
still with us we know what's at stake we
know what's required we know what to do
to take care
we're starting to see an increase in
influenza cases so staying diligent to
keep ourselves our loved ones and our
communities safe is just that much more
important
in addition to covid-19 and influenza
this year we have other viruses that
cause respiratory illnesses such as RSV
which has not been as present in past
years although it was present last year
who agree but is is has been a factor
that we're dealing with as well
we know as the weather gets colder we
will gather more indoors and we know
that's okay but after all we've been
through we also know it's important to
do it safely
that means especially wearing a mask if
we have mild symptoms and considering
wearing a mask in indoor public spaces
it means most importantly staying home
when we're sick and it means washing our
hands frequently with soap and water as
critical as these essential actions are
keeping us to keeping us healthy and
safe getting vaccinated is our best
protection we know this
so we all need to act right away to
register and book an appointment for our
covid-19 and influenza shots it's never
been easier and we see that in the
extraordinary take up already and we can
safely get the two shots at the same
time
as British Columbians we demonstrate our
commitment to protecting ourselves our
loved ones and our communities by
following Public Health guidelines and
getting vaccinated in record numbers
more than 90 percent of us over age 12
have received at least two doses of the
covid-19 vaccine this number grows every
day
and since the fall covid-19 booster
program began on September 1st nearly
1.2 million fall boosters have been
administered to people in BC over the
age of 12 96 percent of which are by
bivalent vaccine products and as of this
morning over 1.2 million of us have
received our flu shots that's more than
twice as much as this time last year we
started earlier and that has an impact
we're also seeing a very strong take up
but we need that to continue
but simply we know what's at stake and
we know what's required and we know what
to do to take care and it's now my honor
to introduce Dr Bonnie Henry to discuss
the respiratory illness season this fall
and winter Dr Henry
all right thank you very much it's a an
honor to be here today it's been a while
I do would like to acknowledge that
we're here on the traditional
territories of the local speaking people
the songis and Esquimalt First Nations
we're very grateful to that I also want
to point out that today is Louis realde
which is a time to learn and celebrate
metis history values and culture and the
first step that we've learned in Truth
and Reconciliation is truth and I
encourage everyone to make an effort to
learn about the truth behind the role
that Louis real played and the unique
Heritage and inherent rights of metis
peoples in this country and in this
province
in September we talked about what we
might expect as we moved into the
respiratory illness season here in
British Columbia we're now in that place
as expected and the respiratory season
is unfolding as we expected it would but
we are in a very different place than we
were a year ago and that is largely
because we've done a number of things we
started to move again to travel to
travel internationally to travel
globally to travel across the country to
travel within the province and we are
seeing the return of common respiratory
viruses that have been mostly absent in
the last two years
we know that the three main viruses we
need to pay attention to and be careful
about are now covid-19 is into that mix
but also influenza and RSD and there are
a number of other respiratory viruses
that have been causing illness and I'll
be walking through us through walking us
through that now
our Focus throughout this pandemic and
in every respiratory season prior to the
pandemic has really been about
protecting people who are at highest
risk of severe illness or death
protecting our health care System our
capacity and we know that's been
stretched for many reasons not the least
of which is respiratory illnesses and
keeping our communities our families and
our communities safe and functioning for
all the other important things that we
need to do which includes bringing
people safely back together again
so I'm going to start with talking about
where we are today
only about 51 percent of eligible
children have received their first dose
of covid-19 vaccines and I'm going to
show some data about why we need to pay
attention to that a year ago we didn't
have vaccines for children we now do and
that's an important piece of protecting
children from a virus that we know
doesn't cause severe illness in most
children but can and we know that
children can also be part of
transmitting it within households and
families particularly
we know that over 86 percent of people
five and over have received at least two
doses of covid-19 vaccines and that is
great that means that we have a level of
immunity that is higher than we've ever
had and that we know that that gives us
longer term protection against severe
illness even in people who are who have
um immune compromising conditions and in
older people
and most importantly we also know that a
large proportion of British Columbians
have received a booster dose and the
fall booster is incredibly important
right now
we now have more protection against
severe illness because of this because
of vaccination but also as we presented
in September we also have infection
induced immunity and we have treatments
we have treatments for covid-19
including paxilovid and we have
treatments for influenza including
Coastal tamavir
so we know from the zero prevalence that
about 90 percent of people in British
Columbia have built some immunity to the
virus through vaccination through
infection or for many people both but we
are also learning that our immunity is
complex and I've talked about this many
times we have that short-term protection
with antibodies in our blood that
respond when we're exposed to the virus
and we know that those antibodies
protect against getting infected having
that virus cause infection in the first
place but we know that whether those
antibodies are from previous infection
or from vaccine they do go down over
time and usually that's around somewhere
about three or four months we start to
see a decrease in that protection
against infection but as we've talked
about many times we know that that
longer lasting second part of our immune
system the memory cells the cell
mediated immunity mat lasts much longer
and give strong protection against
severe illness hospitalization and death
after two doses but also that gets
boosted up if when you have a booster
dose so the combination now of immunity
from infection and vaccination and the
combinations that we've seen and it's it
is complex people have had two doses and
one infection or three Doses and an
infection or several infections and then
vaccination and all of that builds a
complex picture of immunity that makes
it challenging for us to to
tailor who needs what what we do know is
that right now it's really important for
people to get that booster dose to
protect us all from infection and help
dampen down the transmission of covid-19
and we know that the the combinations
we've seen mean that most people in BC
are no longer at risk of severe illness
and hospitalization even in long-term
care even people who are immune
compromised and that is really important
so what are we seeing right now in terms
of hospitalizations and deaths as you
know our testing now is focused on
people who are who will need a
potentially need treatment or may end up
with more severe illness and so that's
not a reflection of amount of
transmission that's happening in our
community but what is important is
following the people who have severe
illness and as we've seen in the last
few weeks our hospitalization rate has
actually started to come down which is
good news the daily deaths as we started
um back in in April reporting on all
cause mortality at 30 days that has has
trickled along and is also coming down
slightly we know that the cause of death
the underlying cause of death being
covered is only about 40 percent of
those I'll have a bit more information
about that so if we look at
hospitalization rates by age we all
along in this pandemic we have seen that
it is older people that are more likely
to get severe illness more likely to be
in hospital and more likely to die and
thankfully with the booster dose program
that we've started and focusing on
primarily making sure that people who
are older get that that dose we have now
started to see decrease in
hospitalization in particularly people
over the age 80 which is the highest
risk group for covet
of our 30-day mortality as you know
um as we get the underlying cause of
death data from Vital Statistics we see
that about 40 30 to 40 percent of people
who die with a positive covet test covet
is one of the reasons why
um they've died and that's remained
relatively steady through the last
several months
if we look again at hospitalizations and
we standardize it by age
again clearly we see that anybody
compared to the same age person who's
non-vaccinated people who are vaccinated
with at least two doses have half the
rate of hospitalization critical care or
risk of dying and the same and that
again is four times higher if we look at
people who've had at least one booster
dose
really important to remember that this
makes a difference this makes a
difference for your own personal health
but it also makes a difference on your
risk of ending up in hospital or passing
it on to others
the most prevalent lineages as you as
you know through this whole pandemic
we've been doing a whole genome
sequencing to help us understand what is
being transmitted around the community
in British Columbia and there's a whole
large gray part in the most recent ones
so this is when Omicron the pink and
purple are are Omicron and the purple
different shades of purple are basically
ba5
and as we have reduced the amount of PCR
testing we're doing there there remains
a whole bunch of others that we need to
look at but we have been sequencing
those others and this is what makes up
that gray box as you can see it's a
whole variety of slightly different
mutations but all of these are Omicron
ba5 so that's really important and we've
seen The evolutionary virologists have
told us that we're seeing what they call
a Confluence where there's not a new
strain that's arising that's causing
very different symptoms or very
different transmission rates what we're
seeing is it's all different variations
around the same sort of variant and most
of it is as a different variance of the
ba5 with slightly different mutations
and so we're continuing to follow that
really closely it is unlikely given what
I've just talked about it with our
immune level of immunity that we have in
British Columbia that we're going to see
something markedly different arise in
the near term here in British Columbia
but we are also watching what's
happening globally because we know that
globally that's where omicon arose but
we would get some warning around if we
started to see a different new strain
arise outside of British Columbia or
Canada
the other thing that we've been
monitoring monitoring carefully is
Wastewater samples and as you can see
we've seen a gradual decrease in
leveling off and it's been a little bit
up and down over the last few weeks but
mostly low and stable and these are the
ones from the Lower Mainland we have now
expanded our Wastewater sampling to the
interior and Island here but we're still
at the point of calibrating those so it
takes some time to get enough data
points to be able to look at Trends over
time but what we are not seeing is any
dramatic increases in the amount of
virus that we're seeing in Wastewater
samples here on the island or in the
interior as well and we're working on
being able to do this in communities in
the north this is something that's
outside of our testing parameters and
changing and testing and it helps us
give it a barometer of what's going on
the other things that we're looking at
and trying to validate are being able to
use these same samples to look at how
much influenza are fee we have
circulating in our community and these
are relatively new techniques it's not
something that's easy to do and so our
lab is at the Forefront of developing
the the ability to do that to help us
understand other viruses that are in our
community as well
so what else is going on in British
Columbia
one of the things that we monitor over
time and this is all on the new
dashboard that we're building on the
bccdc so in the past we've had our
influenza surveillance bulletin that
would come out periodically and now
we've moved it on to a a centralized
database where it's interactive so you
can go on that in the bccdc website and
the link will be in the in the news and
the briefing note so one of the things
that we have been watching over time is
physician builds and and Community
visits to healthcare practitioners so
Physicians nurse practitioners for
respiratory symptoms and so this could
be anything this is a clinical diagnosis
of what we like to call influenza-like
illness so it's anything that's causing
a respiratory symptoms and we can see
that in December and January of last
year we had that big peak and that was
when Omar Khan first came in and we're
now starting to see a gradual and a more
steeper increase within the last two
weeks of respiratory illness in British
Columbia
if we look at that and break it down by
age we see that that increase has been
driven by respiratory illness in young
people and that should be no surprise
we've been seeing that in young younger
people needing ICU care and younger
people going to emergency departments
and seeking treatment across the
province
one of the things that that we see
though is it's across all age groups we
know that school-aged children are
mixing more but also younger children
and it's important to to reflect on that
because there are things that we need to
do to to think about protecting younger
children as well
if we look at what's causing that
illness especially in the last little
while we look at a laboratory data that
helps us understand what pathogens are
causing illness and this comes from
swabs that are taken of people with
influenza like illness or respiratory
illness across the province and is we do
laboratory tests to to look at a variety
of pathogens and what we can see is that
for the last couple of months one of the
main causes of respiratory illness
across the province has been
enteroviruses and rhinoviruses and those
are ones that we call the common cold
and enteroviruses in particular can also
cause some more severe illness we've
seen EVD enterovirus D68 which is one
particular strain of the virus that can
cause more severe illness in children
and that has been one of the drivers of
children needing hospital care or
medical care over the last few months
in the last week and a half we've also
seen you can see in a purple line there
that dramatic increase in influenza and
this is almost all influenza A mostly
influenza a H3 and N1 although we
haven't figured that out yet in
particular so our H3N2 and and H1N1
what we've seen though is a leveling off
of SARS cov2 so that's not what's
causing most of the the respiratory
illness that we're seeing right now and
we've seen an uptick in RSV not the
dramatic increase that we're seeing in
influenza but still an important
increase
if we look at the the BC Children's
Hospital laboratory data which is
something that gives us an understanding
of what's happening in younger people
across the province it's representative
but not inclusive and if we look at the
um the the upper picture has the smaller
picture has uh um uh sarsko V2 included
and then if we take that out because
that was the large proportion we saw
lots of younger people
be having Omicron essentially since
January of last year but if we take that
out the light green is RSV and so we did
see NBC a fair amount of RSV circulating
last winter and that's important to note
one of the concerns that we've had and
that I've talked about is that we have
several cohorts of young people who have
not never been exposed to rvest feed
before which which we're seeing in some
parts of the country particularly
Ontario we're seeing a lot of that where
RSV is causing not more severe your
illness but because more children have
not yet developed immunity to it because
they weren't exposed to it over the last
few years it's causing an increased
numbers of children requiring hospital
care we're not seeing the same picture
yet here in BC and though we're
continuing to watch we did have quite a
lot of RSV circulating last fall and
we're starting to see it increase now
but what we're really seeing that's
making a difference in this province
right now in children is influenza in
influenza A in particular
so the other thing that this says so
I'll just talk about through these
quickly so if we look at SARS cov2 and
at the Children's Hospital we can see
very small numbers and and the percent
positivity sort of bouncing around in
small numbers
um so it's not the main driver of what's
causing people to need hospital care
right now
RSV is increasing and the percent
positivity of the test is increasing the
number of children requiring the test
has has increased as well but really
where we're seeing the big increase in
in young people is influenza and I say
this to make the point really
importantly influenza is a vaccine
preventable disease we have good
vaccines that work well in children
children over the age of six months of
age are eligible for influenza vaccine
for free there's also the nasal spray
influenza vaccine that's available for
children that's very effective and this
is a warning to us we're starting to see
influenza circulating we know that
children often don't get very sick with
it but some of them do but they can also
pass it on to others so this is the time
to make sure we're best protecting
children by getting them vaccinated
against this virus in particular
I want to just talk a little bit about
it's not possible now to tell if you
have symptoms of covid influenza
enterovirus RSV they all cause very
similar types of illness in most people
across the board but the actions we take
to prevent the transmission and to look
after ourselves are the same one of the
things that we've had in place for a
long time is saying if you have covid
you need to stay home for five days
that's no longer relevant in the setting
that we are in now
instead if you have symptoms of any
respiratory illness we we suggest you
well we recommend the guidance is to
stay home and to limit close contact
with others until you no longer have a
fever and you're well enough to
participate in your usual daily
activities that's what we need to think
about it's the the symptoms themselves
it's hard to differentiate if it's one
or the other and it doesn't really
matter in terms of our risk to others
but we need to be cautious we need to be
cautious and that means if you have any
symptoms at all even mild symptoms wear
a mask when you're around others even in
the home and one of the things that
where masks actually are more effective
is when you're in close contact indoors
with somebody and we know that many of
these viruses are transmitted within
families between siblings between
parents and and children grandparents
and others in those settings where we
don't think about wearing masks and and
it is particular if you have somebody
who's more vulnerable within your
household or you have an infant you can
protect them by trying to keep people
who are sick away from them as much as
possible and to wear masks in those
settings if you're sick at all
postponing non-essential close contact
with people who may be at higher risk or
at higher risk of getting sicker with
these viruses so seniors Elders infants
in particular and young children and
those are immune compromised if you can
postpone those visits that would be
particularly bringing children in to
visit people in long-term care when
there's a lot of viruses around and
people have the sniffles it's it's very
risky that you can bring that into a
higher risk setting
if you can't postpone those those
non-essential visits then it is
important to reduce the amount of time
that you spend in the in the place to
wear a mask and to take all of those
other measures like hand hygiene looking
at ventilation looking at whether you
can do it Outdoors Etc
we also need to avoid those social
settings especially indoors where we may
inadvertently spread to others so move
the visit outside wear a mask as I
mentioned think about not taking
children along if there is illness
circulating in their class or in their
in the family
if you do have symptoms but it's
essential to be in close contact with
others then we need to use all of our
preventive tools so masking washing
hands following respiratory etiquette
paying attention to space and distance
and ventilation and that goes for common
spaces like workplaces schools to reduce
risks of transmission
and I would like to take a minute to
talk about masks and where they are most
useful last year we had mask mandates
but they were not in isolation it was in
the context of what we were facing at
the time including severe illness in
many adults as the immunization was
increasing but not yet at the level that
we needed we had no vaccines available
for children
we had adults who are getting very sick
and and putting pressure on our icus and
hospitals plus we had absenteeism of
health care workers and many workplaces
outside of healthcare were working from
home we had Gathering restrictions and
travel restrictions and barriers and
capacity limits we had reduced
activities in schools and in that
context Mass were incredibly important
and necessary in a broad range of
settings including the structured
settings like workplaces and Transit and
schools
we are in a different situation now as
I've mentioned we have a very high level
of immunity against covid we have both
immunity through vaccinations for
influenza and treatments we have
treatments for influenza we have
treatments for uh covert we have
treatments for RSV
Mass still need to be available and
accepted in workplaces on Transit and
other indoor settings
we know that we had last year for
example restricted activities for
children and that had consequences for
the way schools functioned and for the
health and well-being of children
we have learned through this pandemic
the critical role that schools play not
just for children but for families and
communities and it is more than just
education in a school setting as we know
it's the physical emotional social needs
that school communities provide for
children and families and we've pulled
together in this province to ensure that
we keep these essential environments
open and I really again our gratitude
goes to all of the Educators staff and
parents and communities who made this a
safe reality for our children
I will also say every single School in
British Columbia has had a ventilation
assessment and the we continue to make
that a priority we have a committee that
is continuing to meet weekly to review
what's happening in schools we're
monitoring absenteeism
and schools remain a supportive
inclusive environments where masks are
available in every class and where it is
accepted and encouraged to wear a mask
whenever people feel they need to
but I think we all need to recognize we
are all human and mass are protective
equipment but there only is as effective
as we make them and that can be a
challenge especially for children
sometimes and I do not believe we need
that heavy hand of a mandate to send a
clear message that mass are an important
tool that we can all use during this
time and in every respiratory season we
should have one with us we should use it
in situations where it um where it makes
sense
and it may differ depending on the
situation I think about it you know I
may wear a mask one day on the bus if
it's crowded the windows are closed or
if I'm worried that I might be getting
the sniffles but on another day if I'm
feeling fine and there's it's there's
lots of space and good ventilation I may
choose not to and that's okay I think
those are the decisions we have to bring
mass in as a tool that we can use when
it's appropriate when it's necessary
if I have a sick child at home I may
wear a mask in my workplace to be extra
cautious even though I'm feeling well
and I need to go and I can go into work
or I may participate in a meeting where
there's more people in a crowded setting
remotely rather than in person
the settings where masking continues to
be essential are in healthcare settings
and we have a mandate in all of our
health care settings across this
province at all times these tools are
necessary all the time so we have
vaccination requirements for health care
workers across our across our health
care settings in this province and
everybody in long-term care hospitals
vaccination clinics Community clinics
wears masks throughout this respiratory
season these are important additional
measures in those places where it makes
that matters the most and additional
measures we have in long-term care are
including that residents are protected
through testing and ensuring visitors
are also vaccinated
all of these are important but our best
protection remains protecting us from
getting infected in the first place
through immunization and as we can see
we have very high rates of immunization
and high rates of boosters protecting
people a particularly at older age but
we have work to do for younger children
so I encourage everybody now is the time
to make that appointment you can get
your influenza vaccination your covet
booster at the same time
as well as I mentioned there's nasal flu
shots for children and flu vaccines are
available to everyone six months of age
and older
uh the other thing that is different
this year is that we have enhanced
influenza vaccines for all seniors over
the age of 65 and those give additional
protection against influenza influenza
than the standard dose vaccines because
they stimulate a stronger immune
response so I encourage everyone to
register and book your appointment for
your your flu shot and your fall booster
now
correct
so as we we are going through the
respiratory season and as I mentioned we
knew that this was coming and we've been
preparing for this as best we can and
the things that we all do together
collectively now will make a difference
in as we get through this next few
months
as we all look forward to the holiday
season as well it's important to keep
our personal toolkit handy we have many
tools that can help protect us our loved
ones our community from all of these
viruses that are circulating now first
and foremost is getting vaccinated but
also having a mask with you wearing it
in those crowded indoor settings wearing
it when you're not sure if you have the
sniffles or not doing that health check
every day for yourself and your children
avoiding touching your face and eyes and
nose using respiratory adequate coughing
in your sneeze covering your cough
disposing of your tissues remembering
your hand hygiene you can also choose
where you gather and when you gather
with friends and family looking for Open
Spaces with good airflow you know
looking at postponing some of those
visits if there's illness in the family
regularly cleaning surfaces paying
attention to ventilation
and if you're feeling unwell stay home
and avoid contact with others especially
people who may be more at risk
I want to thank everybody in British
Columbia for their continued commitment
and we've seen this all along of
recognizing that we're all coming from
different places and that we need to be
supportive of each other if you're
wearing a mask today given the situation
that you're in we need to be supportive
of that too
and that means this is how we're going
together to get through this respiratory
season and practice get it and be part
of how we do this every year as we know
that these viruses are going to be
coming around again thank you and I'll
turn it back to minister news
thank you Dr Henry yeah Dr Henry is
leaving me with clicker which is a high
oh you're gonna oh yeah only one person
has the clicker here so thank you Dr
Henry uh this is going to go on with uh
uh presentation with respect to uh
current hospitalization status where we
are and uh where we expect to be uh in
September we said that we had to prepare
our hospitals for Respiratory illness
season and a possible surge in patients
our hospitals have well-established
systems in place to manage High patient
volumes including Regional and
provincial surge plans they've been
planning for various scenarios and are
ready to respond to an influx of
patients requiring care for Respiratory
illnesses plans are in place and
fortunately in large measure we are not
at a point where we need to implement
them yet but we're ready if we need to
our Readiness plans include improving
and increasing a hospital bed capacity
and emergency department efficiency we
go on to the next slide which I think is
this one no it's back when we're still
on that one yeah
in terms of capacity in October covid-19
hospitalizations as Dr Henry has said
we're down and but
they're relatively similar to September
levels Hospital occupancy is up from
September Rising by one point to 95.4
percent of Base bed capacity and when we
include surge bets in those numbers the
occupancy increase this point in
November is 2.2 percent
we see that reflected in that slide
there's a lot of interest in children's
Critical Care capacity I would note that
this changes and as you can see can
change significantly from day to day
because overall in the province we have
uh amongst children's high Acuity beds
and neonatal intensive care beds we have
243 beds but a change of one or two can
very significantly change the
information speed site for example on
Monday there was an over capacity at
Kelowna general hospital today we are
under capacity for that because there's
a small number of beds and the reduction
or two or three can significantly change
those numbers the Pediatric ICU rates
tend to change more of course as we've
set but essentially we are at as of
today as of yesterday it was 67 percent
I think we reported that in our
children's Critical Care bed stay at 64
percent in terms of our children's high
Acuity units it's up slightly from 74 to
76 from yesterday to today to give you a
sense of the day-to-day changes the next
slide please
you see in terms of emergency department
visits over the last period we have seen
an increase overall in November on
average from where we are in September
and October and September and October
was roughly 6 700 visits a day in
November that number is up to
6765. understanding that at different
sites that can be a varied amount on
different days next slide please
in terms of bed management our emergency
department and Hospital capacity task
group is integrating priority actions
into health authority surge response
plans these plans include improving
emergency department triage processes to
better and more quickly connect patients
with Community Care to avoid or shorten
hospital stays they also include hiring
more patient care coordinators to
improve the flow of patients through
hospitals and heightening integration
with urgent and Primary Care Centers and
strengthening Communications to patients
as well as ensuring support to Rural and
remote care and all of the Investments
we've made in patient transport
next slide
uh pediatric in terms of pediatric icus
we have a dedicated provincial pediatric
team that coordinates our pediatric
resources we have pediatric icu's of
course located at BC Children's Victoria
General and University of Northern
British Columbia and neonatal ICU beds
in in
many jurisdictions in many hospitals
across the province this dedicated team
is focused on a daily basis on on one at
stake and responding to the demands of
respiratory illness season and so you
see that and you see that in the
response specifically at that care and
some of the numbers I spoke about just a
few minutes ago if we move on to the
next slide
in terms of increasing our capacity in
community this was a part of our plants
and that means something in a term which
I'll I'll explain it's called alternate
level of care or ALC patients
essentially those are patients who are
in hospital but are really ready or
should be in long-term care and they're
being provide hospital care as they
either wait for a long-term care chance
for an available bet and that is one of
the ways that we measure
patient flow in the system and also it's
a possible place where you can create a
capacity in the system by creating more
access to long-term care beds in the in
the community and that's precisely what
we've been doing we've seen in October a
reduction of ALC patients as a
percentage of occupied beds that is
decreased and we have specific measures
we'll um that we put in place including
the opening of of beds to ensure that
we're ready as we need to address
potential demands on capacity from
respiratory illnesses and so we're
adding beds across all Health
authorities in long-term care to allow
for more space in acute care this is not
an issue of moving acute care patients
to long-term care it's it's a case of
patients who are long-term care patients
but in acute care moving over to
long-term care and creating capacity at
a time when their capacity pressures in
the system
and there's lots of details by Health
authorities and you all have the
PowerPoint and I'll let you go through
those
and uh the next slide I think
that's it yep just to say finally that
you know
um we're opening long-term care beds and
we're supporting operators uh of
long-term care beds who are often Health
authorities are often uh private
for-profit or non-profit providers
including Staffing float teams and
virtual nursing services and providing
casual staff with more flexible
opportunities for regular part-time and
full-time work we're implementing
strategies for patients who can be
supported at home including providing
casual staff opportunities for regular
full-time and part-time work adding
capacity and home support and in adult
day programs and ensuring quicker access
to Transitional Care for complex
patients discharged from the hospitals
our hospitals need to be ready and as
you can see from Dr Henry's presentation
we need to continue to be ready as we go
through this season we are
behind thankfully other jurisdictions in
the country in terms of these pressures
but we need to prepare for them and we
all finally with those plans in place
need to do our part we need to be ready
too we need to get vaccinated we need to
wear a mask especially if we have mild
symptoms we have mild symptoms we need
to stay home if we're sick and we need
to wash our hands frequently and we need
to keep doing what we know because what
we know works and with that Dr Henry and
I are happy to take your questions
thank you a reminder to media on the
line please press star one to enter the
queue for the opportunity to ask a
question and a follow-up we're going to
start here in the room today first
question comes from Bender sagin CTV
News bag
um just wondering if you're a parent of
a child who gets uh fairly sick I know
we've talked about the ICU numbers
um but you're heading to hospital often
facing hours long Waits whether you're
you know ABC Children's or at other
hospitals around the province so I know
you've talked about the work that's
being done does that help immediately
though for the people who are waiting
hours and hours and hours and what
advice do you give parents who are very
worried about their their sick little
ones yeah so I I know this is a
challenge that we Face a lot and it's so
hard to do with with young children
particularly so I encourage people to
talk to their primary care provider to
call 8-1-1 where they can get advice as
well and yes when you do go to emergency
departments some of them are very busy
but if you are concerned about your
child don't put off that visit if you
need to go to the emergency department
you will be seen you will be triaged and
we will only need to be patient but we
know that it is important to get that
care if you need it I don't know if you
want to talk about it it is a challenge
so say the important way that the
capacity changes are important is it
creates space on the wards sometimes
you'll hear a story of someone who's
admitted to the hospital but then in the
emergency room and it's an important
measure of patient flow in the hospital
and that sounds like a technical thing
but it's important we want people who
who are sick and are admitted to the
hospital to be on the wards because that
allows less pressure and less sense of
pressure in emergency room so it's
important for that reason and
fundamentally if you don't have space in
there admitted they have to stay in the
emergency room and that's a problem for
everybody who works in the emergency
room so that's why one of the reasons
it's important is it's a capacity issue
that's important as to all the measures
we're taking adding patient care
coordinators and others to help people
in those periods we have at different
hospitals on consecutive days sometimes
significantly different numbers of
patients coming in and as Dr Henry has
said everyone gets triaged right and
it's and it's a challenge sometimes
there are other services available
811 prior to the pandemic we did about a
thousand fifty calls a day at the height
of the pandemic that was over four
thousand in a day so we dramatically
expanded that Services come back down to
a sort of daily average about eighteen
hundred a check every morning to see how
we're doing in response to those calls
whether we're losing them yesterday we
responded to I think over 99 of the
calls right so we have created capacity
there to assist and obviously through
the other actions we're taking but it's
it's a challenging time it's challenging
for healthcare workers we sometimes have
reported on a number of health care
workers who are off sick that typically
in the pre-coveted era that would be
um on on a one of the basis of
healthcare workers we use about eight to
nine thousand workers last week is about
fifteen thousand nine hundred and of
course that sickness comes in
consistently across the problems and can
hit an entire group of workers in a
particular part on the acute care
hospital whatever the nature of the
illness is so that's one of the
challenges facing the Health Care system
in every part of the country and even
and certainly here in BC follow-up
Bender yeah
yeah Dipper on a day-to-day basis I know
you talk about having like surge beds
available but if you do have healthcare
workers are all who are off sick you're
not necessarily I guess Staffing those
surge beds until the need is there but
how quickly can you get those staffed up
and how quickly can you get you know and
whether it's you know at a children's
hospital because they know that's a huge
concern right now or other hospitals
like how quickly can that happen can
people be confident that that happens
within hours a day a week I'm not I'm
not sure how long it takes well I'll
talk to a little bit and then turn to it
for two but you know we one of the
reasons we've set up the eocs the
Emergency Operations centers I get
children's hospital and and the
provincial one that we have is to be
able to do that on a day-to-day basis so
children's hospital they look at all of
the Pediatric beds around the province
and look at how they can staff up in the
areas where they're needed and it varies
very
rapidly so sometimes it's a day by day
thing and it is dependent very much on
health care workers and so there are
systems and processes that we have put
in place and these Emergency Operations
centers to be able to do that on a
day-to-day basis so it is rapid the the
equipment the pieces are there so it is
finding the healthcare workers to
transition into the places where they're
needed most and that's the day-to-day
work that people are doing across the
province right now as we're heading into
more and more respiratory illness
field
I mean I think
um you're absolutely right to the extent
that the more the higher the population
the hospital the more pressure there is
in the system and it's unequally felt
one of the places where I think our
healthcare workers and nurses have done
exceptional work as well in that
hospital which has a base bed capacity
of 258 and it hasn't been at 258
in many many weeks and when I say many
many weeks I say more than 52 right so
they adjust with surge bed capacity all
the time as do all hospitals but you
want to relieve to the maximum extent
possible and there we open long-term
care beds at Ponderosa during the
pandemic to create capacity and if
necessary and this is not necessary yet
and we are doing record numbers of
surgeries in our health care System
every month which is I think an
extraordinary achievement of the
surgical renewal commitment that we put
in place but if necessary those steps
are available as well you'll recall a
year ago and that was the delta a
variant of concern that we had to
transport people from icus in the
northern health authority in particular
in the hundreds down to the southern
health authority so we have levels of
action that we take in our emergency
responses we're not there and we don't
want to be there and part of the reason
that we prepared every year for what
would come in respiratory illness season
is to prepare for exactly those
scenarios but it it is not easy I mean
it's just not easy and if you have some
people who are off sick and especially
in a smaller hospital it can profoundly
affect your ability to deliver service
which is sometimes why we have
diversions right because they're they're
simply people are off sick and you
simply can't replace them a small period
of time safely so you go on diversion
which is very disconcerting for people
and and we we know that and you've been
reporting on that so those are some of
the challenges facing the system so we
are able to but there are limits and
once you once those numbers go up and up
and up and up then you have to take
other actions the reason we deferred
surgery surgeries at different times in
the pandemic in March of 2020 because we
weren't sure what was going to happen
and then during the Omicron variant of
concern was to reduce Hospital capacity
so we could care for more patients we
don't want to do that it takes enormous
effort to make up that ground and we've
been doing it but those are there's lots
of options available to us but obviously
some of those those options all have
other consequences that we don't want to
see happen and that's why we're taking
these preventative steps next question
Von Palmer Vancouver son
any hesitation over bringing back a mask
mandate because of the view that the
public has moved on and it would be hard
to enforce the mass mandating if you
brought one in
um I think I tried to explain that
mask mandates were in the context of
where we needed them to be worn by
everybody over broad areas over broad
settings in the context that we were in
at the time so I don't see a mandate as
being required by itself right now in
the situation that we're in we all need
to learn about that tool and where it is
best used and we're trying to provide
some guidance on that and that's what we
all need to focus on because this is
going to happen every year we're going
to have respiratory season next year and
mass are one of the tools that are
important that work that help in the
situations where where we use the most
so if we're not feeling well if we're
going into a crowded situation with poor
ventilation where people we don't know
those are when we need to wear masks and
that will continue so right now I don't
see the need for a mass mandate by
itself because we have many other tools
and we have a high level of protection
from a variety of these these
respiratory illnesses that are
circulating right now
is there any
Aroma metrics you monitor is there any
in particular that will contribute to
you changing your mind on this yeah you
know we've talked about that a lot you
know when it wouldn't be a mass mandate
in isolation it would be what are the
measures we need to take to prevent
people from getting sick and
overwhelming our health care System
prevent morbidity and mortality sickness
and death and so the situations that I
can see would be an entirely new virus
for which we don't have immunity anymore
where every single one of those tools
needs to be in place in a broad way
across the population so it would be in
the context of other things that need to
be in place too like capacity limits and
restrictions in certain activities then
all of those other things that we needed
to do when we didn't have protection
against something that was causing very
severe illness in the large numbers of
people
next question comes from Richard zissman
Global News you describe a scenario
there
[Music]
close
School situation I know you mentioned
that ventilation has been worked on in
schools but there are still a lot of
unknowns in that situation so why is
there such a reluctance considering that
kids have largely been able to train
themselves to wear masks properly
to put masks in that situation when
we've even seen some studies out of the
U.S that Community spread has gone down
in areas where there's been masking in
schools so just to address those studies
because these are things that we also
have been looking at and it's not that
Community spread has gone down those are
observational studies and it's hard to
know which came first so Community rates
went down masking was part when the
community rates were high Community
rates come down so it's very challenging
they're not cause and effect in those
studies so I I suggest that we have a
lot of data that shows us that schools
are not
uncontrolled environments there are lots
of things that that children do in
schools and it's really important to
normalize that we've put a lot of
pressure on young kids they've suffered
through this pandemic in many many ways
so it is important for us to make it a
very inclusive environment where masks
are there where they're available where
kids can wear them where they are
trained to wear them where it's
normalized when they need to wear them
we're not in a situation right now where
I think every single child and adult in
a school setting has to wear a mask all
the time that's what a mask mandate is
we're not in that situation where we
need to pay attention to are all the
pieces that go together to make it a
safe environment and to give children
what they need in a school environment
which is activities and being in person
all the time the social connections all
of the learning that they do in the in
the school community and school
environment and so that's what we're
focusing on making sure that the
ventilation is paid attention to making
sure we have the cleaning making sure
kids are taught how to clean their hands
and cover them both appropriately and
when to wear masks and to stay home and
to make it easy for children to be able
to to stay away if they're if they're
getting sick
follow up Richard
on the wait time issue
um you know it's really important to get
vaccinated for children that's one of
the best ways we protect them even if
they're not going to get that sick
themselves it's really important on the
wait time issue at BC Children's I know
that Minister Dix went over some
measures that could work to help address
it there people are still facing double
digit hour weights what should parents
do with children looking at that
situation considering in some cases they
are having a hard time accessing
that of course provincial Health officer
Bonnie Henry and previously Health
Minister Adrian dicks answering
questions from reporters they've been
discussing flu season and respiratory
illness while reminding the public to
get covet and flu shots as well as to
wash your hands and stay home if you're
sick they say they've seen a large
number of kids coming to hospital due to
influenza and when it comes to masks
there's no mandate but they do recommend
using one especially in areas that might
be crowded if you feel like you might be
able to catch something we'll have more
on this coming up throughout the day and
next on Global BC at noon
foreign
not to delay going to the emergency
department call 8-1-1 get some advice
but if you need to go the emergency
department will be there for you and we
are working behind the scenes to make
sure that we maximize that as much as
possible
and I think it detailed some of the
measures we're taking specifically with
respect to emergency rooms to assist
people who are visiting who are coming
to emergency rooms especially with
children on a given day including
increasing support for patient care
coordinators the work that we're doing
in most hospitals which is really
important BC Children's is a little bit
specific because obviously we're not we
don't have ALC beds in BC Children's
Hospital so it's a specific circumstance
but all of the things we're putting in
place we've put in place including the
expanded capacity at 811 including we've
added a couple in the last few weeks
urgent in Primary Care Centers which
have taken 1.5 million visits in our and
take thousands of visits across the
province every day and coordinating
those more uh more closely with
emergency rooms and the work we're doing
to both get people and get people
supports at home so that they can leave
hospitals sooner one of the challenges
in the emergency room
uh in general and if you're a child
outside of the Metro Vancouver you see
this one of the challenges the emergency
room is ensuring that there's access on
Wards so that people can be transferred
to the wards and it takes off the
overall pressure on the emergency room
because that can be uh problematic for
the delivery of care and obviously
problematic for everyone around the care
it makes it feel more crowded than you
want it to be in those circumstances so
all of those steps that we're taking are
important and obviously on the primary
care question we've we've recently
worked working with the province's
doctors and all the work we're doing
with other groups including and
especially nurses and Health Sciences
professionals and healthcare workers to
increase the attachment to a family
doctor and I think those are that's work
that we did together we've signed a
historic agreement that's waiting to be
ratified and we put interim measures in
place both to to facilitate you to
practice as doctors to provide care in
the community we're taking steps on
internationally educated doctors and of
course the transitional funding which
which is in place through to January
31st support doctors in the communities
but look it's a difficult time like this
is
we have seen and we are seeing some
significant increased demands and we
respond to those demands there have been
an increase for example in Vancouver
Coastal Health in gynecological
referrals so our team of Surgeons met
last week and we will be increasing that
capacity in the coming few weeks so we
are we respond systematically and that's
why the organization that's been in
place in BC's Health Care System since
January 2020 which has really been an
emergency organization of the system
continues to be needed and required
especially this fall and winter
moving to the phones now our first
question comes from Andrea Wu Globe and
Mail
hi there there is a recent research
showing that even among those who have
been immunized each subsequent covet
infection raises a person's risk of
serious complications including
hospitalization death or development of
disorders affecting the lungs brain and
heart and the body's blood
musculoskeletal and gastrointestinal
systems does that not warrant a stronger
Public Health response Beyond widespread
vaccination especially given that we
know that immunity does Wane after a few
months yeah I guess you know we have to
put it in context and I'm aware of that
study
and there's many of those studies that
have varying results about impact and
some of its short-term some of it
potentially longer term but what we are
also seeing on the ground is that we're
not seeing as many people develop long
coveted symptoms particularly after
vaccination we know that vaccination
reduces that risk by at least half maybe
more we since Omicron we are also not
seeing as many people with infections
who are developing longer term symptoms
so I think we have to put that in the
context of we know that that
those broad measures that we took to
prevent transmission had downside
impacts on people's Health as well so if
we look at the things that you could do
so more Public Health measures it would
be stopping sick people from being
around well people and that's hard to do
it's hard to know when somebody can
transmit potentially asymptomatically we
know that happens with influenza so we
only need to look at places like China
for example where they are continuing to
try and do that to recognize that there
are very severe downtight impacts on
communities on
families and on individual so I think
what we need to do is recognize that the
best protection we have is vaccination
and put in place all of the other things
that we do individually and collectively
to try and get us through this this
virus is going to be with us so we have
to find that balance of not causing more
harm from the measures that we put in
place and doing our best to protect
people and we've seen I mean our
evidence is clear that if you're
vaccinated and with a level of of hybrid
immunity that we have right now most
people are not going to get severe
illness with covet so we have to put in
place things that are commensurate with
the risk that we're seeing right now
follow up Andrea
uh yes please how many pediatric
elective surgeries have been canceled or
postponed in response to the increase in
respiratory infections today
I'm not aware of any of them in this
province
I mean there are on a on a daily basis
occasionally surgeries that are canceled
but essentially across the system
we've been doing record numbers of
surgeries I'm happy and ordinarily in
these reports when they occur on
Thursday and we'll have the numbers come
in on Thursday we'll let you know how
many surgeries have been performed in BC
but prior to the pandemic we really
never hit 7000 surgeries we've hit that
Mark consistently and that obviously
includes pediatric surgeries at a
particular site there may be issues on a
particular circumstance for example a
surgeon Falls ill or a surgical nurse
false nil it affects the delivery of the
surgery in that case but in general
we're delivering surgeries at the very
high level and at historically high
levels right now across the province
that is one place should the situation
become more challenging where you can
adjust to allow for more capacity in the
system but it's obviously not desirable
to delay surgeries that people need
since all the surgeries would deliver in
the Public Health Care system are
medically necessary
and for another question from the phones
before we come back to the room next we
hear from Wilderness Paul rajio Canada
um
she said
he can't say Do not systems
in exceptional important news is
foreign
um
uh
the Dr Henry is the question
um
Circumstance
the protein mask for water protection a
a la Protection
Program
systems you
respiratory
[Music]
final question from the phones before we
finish here in the room Lisa used US
city news 11 30.
hi there Minister sir I'm just going to
take it over here and identify this
I'm just gonna dress specifically the
wait times at ERS for children and for
adults what is being done to address
that and I know you talked about it a
bit earlier and I'm sorry if I missed
the entire answer so um what we're
seeing across the province is a relative
increase right we used to use this
number of about 6500 which is average in
front before covet 19. I was going to
say Kobe designer covid-19
in NBC in the in the in November so far
our average is
6765. that's differently felt at
different hospitals and in different
communities so we put in place as we do
in periods of high volume which are by
the way every year during respiratory
illness season but it's more important
this year because of covid-19 in
addition to influenza so we put in place
a number of measures and we're putting
continuing to put in place measures to
ensure that those who can be in
long-term care and are slated in
long-term care that some of those people
are able to move to long-term care to
create more space in the hospital this
allows us to improve flow from emergency
room and that's really important for
everybody who works there and everyone
who gets care we're putting in place
more patient care coordinators we have
resources for example at 811 available
for people to get advice on the phone
and people are using those resources
we've seen a very significant increase
in utilization during covid-19 but we've
maintained the resources for example
yesterday to answer the 1800 calls that
we received through the 811 line and
we're increasing the collaboration
between urgent and Primary Care Centers
and ERS across the province there are
now more than 30 urgent and Primary Care
Centers and they've seen more than 1.5
million patients now up to date which is
a pretty significant contribution as
well so all of these steps are being
taken they're important steps but we
have to know and we have to know in this
period of respiratory illness that there
is going to be and is more pressure on
emergency rooms you see it in the
numbers but you see it in the reality of
those emergency rooms and it can be in
different emergency rooms different on
different days and that means that uh
that if you need to go to an emergency
room go you will be triaged and it may
take some time because we triage cases
so if if
your child or your case or an adult's
case is less serious in other cases they
are going to be seen first that is the
way we operate emergency rooms here and
everywhere else for good reason but
that's the effort that's being made
specific actions to support emergency
rooms now all the steps that we're
taking to reinforce primary care and
specific actions to improve patient flow
in our hospitals which is important for
patients it sounds a technical term
important for patients because it means
that we don't have people stuck in
emergency rooms longer than they need to
be stuck
follow up Lisa
just so the bottom line is that with the
pressures that are coming with this
respiratory season things are not going
to get a lot better for hospitals you
know I know in Metro Vancouver people
wait a long time but but what is being
done what what can be done is being done
but ultimately people are still going to
have to wait
you know and it's going to change on a
day-by-day basis you know the things
that we do as a community to try and
prevent ourselves from getting sick
makes a big difference and those are
things that we can focus on that we can
do getting vaccinated taking those
measures staying away from others so
we're not spreading and if we're sick
ourselves and and using the other tools
in our community like 8-1-1 to get
advice about things but you're right we
have committees the Emergency Operations
centers who are trying to to manage flow
as best we can so that we can make it as
efficient as possible but these are
challenging times and it's challenging
times for healthcare workers who are
doing their best to try and see people
as quickly as possible across the
province
our last question our last question
today comes from Rob buff from CTV
Vancouver Island
parties
also going to be a month keeper into
this virus season how confident are you
that we are not going to see any form of
restrictions whether it's masks or
otherwise implemented then and what kind
of metrics would you need to see to do
that so you know we are heading into
holiday season
um it's it varies year by year when we
see Peaks and how steep those Peaks are
so we're seeing influenza rapidly
increase we've seen covet kind of level
off and go down it's hard to know what's
going to happen and we need to be
prepared for it lasting several weeks
normally what we see is that the holiday
season is an amplifier for influenza
we're seeing it start early now so
really we have the warning now that we
can do things that will make a
difference over the next few weeks and
then we all need to think about what
we're going to do over the holiday
season to make sure that we're not
putting people who are more at risk at
risk so if you've been able to cancel
some of those events if we're staying if
we're sick or somebody's in the in the
family's sick moving it to a safer venue
Outdoors or where there's more space so
those are things that we all need to
think about I don't see us needing
um to put in place additional
restrictions but we're going to watch
this of course and it depends a lot
about the impact on our health care
System how we're managing that and we'll
be watching that very carefully we'll be
looking at how much it goes up who's
getting sick so those are all the things
that we'll be reporting the respiratory
dashboard as I mentioned is updated
every Thursday so people can look
themselves and but traditionally what we
have seen is that comes through in waves
I shouldn't use the term waves it comes
through in in surges in different age
groups different viruses and we've seen
that we've seen enterovirus and now
we're seeing influenza come up um so
we'll be we'll be tracking it really
carefully to see what happens over the
next few weeks but I don't foresee will
have to do broad community-based
measures and the way that we need it to
do last year given the impact that we
saw last year
it's for a colleague who's doing the
story based out of Nanaimo where there's
a woman who was diagnosed with colon
cancer she can't get insurance without a
doctor's note doesn't have access to a
doctor I guess it relates the primary
care again I know the province was
brought in this
new model for funding GPS but before we
reap the benefits of that when you say
to families like this woman and I'm over
struggling to that they can't get a
doctor is there anything that you're
able to do and will do before we see the
benefits of this new model to attract or
routine doctors I was saying what I'd
suggest Rob is if you can communicate
the details uh to my office because I I
understand some of the details of what
the difficulty might be in terms of
getting a doctor's note but I'd be
interested getting all the details and
seeing what we can do to help this
person in those circumstances
in a general sense what we have to
continue to do is when Nanaimo has one
of our most successful for example
urgent and Primary Care Centers which is
um which has had a lot of positive
impact there it's very much integrated
into the primary care system and in fact
operates of the Medical Arts Building
and it's an expansion of the Medical
Arts Center and the and as an expansion
of the services they provide we're
building out Primary Care networks more
than 1200 new people to provide
team-based care across communities and
and so we're providing a lot of those
services and taking a lot of action in
Primary Care the change in the addition
doubling the number of nurse
practitioners and obviously the work
we're doing with doctors but it's
difficult to talk about a specific case
without knowing the details of that case
but if you provide them we would be I'd
be happy to look into it personally and
and see what can be done
okay thank you everybody merciful